hannover damals luca meine liebe freunde
ich bin locker und das ist sandra und
wir stehen heute wäre würde er fragen
wir stellen uns nicht wer würde heute
der erste weihnachtsfeiertag haben wir
beide hier so tolle retis ohren auf und
also ein bisschen nerven
du bist ein tag mit stillstand mit der
frage wer würde ja in einem promis
werden wenn man nicht 100 prozent
natürlich auch sagen
mehr muss man dazu nicht sagen
das mächtige zahl im australischen port
wegen überleben
1000 einfachen prozent persönlich in
peterhof natürlich jeden tag würde er in
die afg antreten
das war geil da er seinen körper
steinmann erstellen lassen mein größter
traum für 1 millionen euro positionieren
[Applaus]
und dann verlieren werden konnte um
schlechten unseren kinderwunsch
durchzuboxen
dies dürfte bereits erhältlichen aber
sehr nette person sparen
herzliche menschen kommen nicht ins bett
[Gelächter]
würde sich ganz spontan anschließen
würde ist ja fraktion erneut war es war
damals attraktionen locken doch nicht
etwas viel jahren unserem chef anfangen
besser als anderes geschlecht ausnehmen
ich hoffe dass unsere mahlzeiten mit
einer schönen aber sonst um augen
charakter und person starb
1000 prozent
1000 leute auf nutzen kommentiert davon
eigentlich jedes mal richtig zu beginnen
ist guter sex aushalten
[Applaus]
kommentar von von beiden fällen was wird
[Musik]
werde erst jetzt öffentlich
kommt man nichts zu sagen
superheld durch die straßen schwingungen
für gerechtigkeit von einem schwingen
würde ja beinahe supertalent gewinner
[Applaus]
ist die anderen also noch gar keine
talente als charakter aus gute zeiten
schlechte zeiten durch
hier ist ins glück bin ich eigentlich
schon dein kommentar bezieht sich immer
so man weil es direkt was du hast bin
ich erst jetzt habe ich auf den anders
ich ferner ferner mit ich sage ich doch
nur hass verwirrt mich dass da keine
punkte spiel
doch für mich ist alles wer würde dir
fragen bei denen man sandra sperber dass
schauspieler beim lesen eine milliarde
prozent ein gewerbe prozent gewesen
ebenfalls angemeldet
am ersten tag der ersten heirat
[Applaus]
gewachsen ist was warum wachsen nicht so
dass auswahl gab mir schon gut zu dem 10
der glaubte die versuche jemand wasser
zu mit nächstenliebe money money money
[Musik]
wealth report werden
danach weiß nicht mal wie man gibt als
sich direkt an zu stottern und selbst in
der wahrscheinlich nie ausbleibenden
sagen wer von euch mal schneller beim
traurigen film mehr muss ich natürlich
sagen
doch soll ich dazu gesagt aber meiner
meinung das papier ja erstmal nicht
gezahlt wird am ersten haben jetzt 12
ich hatte schon erwartet dass nicht mal
einen partner gewesen wenn supermodel
[Applaus]
beide hersteller gefängnis um das wohnen
nach prozent und 100 prozent aus
unterschiedlichen welt werde frauen
damit es im schnitt damit dass sich am
ehesten in weniger als einer woche
entscheiden lassen
[Applaus]
er ist vegetarier 10 heiko unter 10
millionen prozent 300.000 prozent recht
harmlos
[Applaus]
ja ich habe neben dir übernachtet wer
verliebt sich schneller
90 erst mal ganz realistisch betrachtet
von paletten für ihn verknallt
wer sich zuerst schneller das ist der
unterschied zwischen kanal und vergnügen
also wenn man zwei teams erreicht ist
und so dass man wieder nach oben zu
bleiben sonst so okay wenn sie beklagen
so ist das etwas vom boden
aber egal ob das der gerechte strafen
egal alles ist entgleist ist die marken
hervor das können wir das noch fragen
hat kann ich mich fragen kein skifahren
snowboard gefahren ist weshalb du jetzt
[Applaus]
100 prozent dann habe ich mit meiner
ehrlichkeit gebildet ich schaffe es ist
hier auch vom video meine damen und
herren es euch gefallen hat auch gerne
einen daumen hoch unter dem video sei
dank noch mal an dich fürs mitmachen
sandra megacool wobei es war gestern
weihnachten
die voreilige haben oder rutschen
[Musik]